Shawn is with us in Illinois hey Shawn
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
thank you for taking my call sure I'm
calling because last year I took out a
loan against my 401 K of my old job for
my daughter for her to get through her
senior year in college and I I took out
16 thousand I ended up paying off mm but
I ended up getting another job and
didn't pay the balance now I'm nervous
about that because they said it will go
towards my income with a penalty yeah so
you have the ability to borrow do you
have the ability to borrow twelve
fourteen thousand dollars no you can't
go to the bank and borrow fourteen
thousand dollars I'll probably do but
I'm already in debt no you're already in
debt yeah you owe fourteen thousand
right now and what they're getting ready
to do right now is they're getting ready
to charge you six thousand dollars in
penalties and taxes for this screw-up if
you don't go get a loan and pay it off
with that loan and then you're not going
to get charged $6,000 for the screw-up
you get charged a 10% penalty plus your
tax rate for not repaying a 401k loan
within 60 days of leaving your company
this is why we tell people to never
borrow on their 401 K loans so if I were
you I'd go borrow $14,000 at the credit
union that's going to save you about 6
grand now you're still owe 14 but Joe 14
now otherwise you're back otherwise
you've got to turn 14 into 8 and that 8
is going to get you know your your 401
KS I assume well there's more than that
in your 401 K so they're just going to
cash out enough out of your 401k and pay
this loan off is what they're going to
do they still have my yeah they're
getting ready to take the money out of
that and pay this loan off and charge
you the penalties
oh okay sorry works so yeah what I would
do is borrow the fourteen thousand repay
that to the bank and roll your 401k out
of there into an into an IRA and that
will save you $6,000 otherwise they're
going to cash enough out of your 401k to
pay off the $14,000 loan and pay the
penalties and taxes so they're gonna
take about 20 grand out of your 401 K
that's what they're going to do to pay
off fourteen thousand our loan so this
turned into a you know a fifty five
percent interest rate or something by
the time we're done here yeah
it's a bad plan I'm sorry kiddo I wish
you hadn't done that but this is how you
get out of it now you get us got to roll
up your sleeves and clean up the mess